this is devante chisholm reading for
gabe gerwin assassin's creed valhalla
dawn of ragnarok is a mammoth-sized
expansion it's not a two-hour aside to
play if you're getting tired of the main
game story nor will it just be more
assassin's creed valhalla instead
developer ubisoft sophia's upcoming
expansion is a 35 hour adventure that
makes some massive changes and additions
to the base games formula putting you in
full control of a norse god and their
mythical abilities gamespot was able to
watch a hands-off demonstration of
assassin's creed valhalla dawn of
ragnarok giving us a look at the
svartalfheim region that's only
accessible via volca raventhorpe seer in
a similar manner to asgard and jodenheim
in the main campaign
this land historically told to be ruled
by dwarves has seen the native community
scattered into hiding spots to avoid
destruction and forced labor ubisoft
sophia has avoided the common trope of
having buff bearded dudes with scottish
accents for this role instead depicting
the dwarves as a slightly smaller
human-like race like hobbits but without
the hairy feet or insatiable hunger it
looks to be a good fit for valhalla
offering a more reserved take on
mythology than say the cartoonish and
silly characters of immortals phoenix
rising speaking to gamespot creative
director mikhail lozenov stressed that
the focus on mythology reflected the
daily lives of the people of valhalla's
time period it's for this reason they're
included alongside actual historic
events even if we now have a better idea
of what is real and what was made larger
than life through storytellers he's
he's a traitor
a dwarf working for the mooseballs so
don't you believe a word he tells you
you get a chance you'll kill him
i shall judge who lives and dies
where is this palace lozenoff said quote
they were definitely driving people's
daily lives they were creating the
history we read today because of these
myths because of these beliefs and for
us it felt natural to include avor's
story and to dive deeper into these
memories of odin's dna inside their dna
controlling odin referred to as javi by
their fellow icer and playable as either
male or female your journey into one of
the most dangerous areas of valhalla is
meant as end game content though newer
players can receive a temporary power
and equipment boost if they want to play
it earlier in addition to finding and
hopefully rescuing odin's son boulder
you'll also face off against the
unlikable fire god surter typically an
unlikable enemy isn't exactly an easy
foe and it's unclear how odin can turn
the odds in his favor however he does
have a number of special abilities to
deal with lesser enemies that weren't
available during valhalla's other
mythical excursions acquirable through a
new skill tree they include the power of
the raven which lets odin temporarily
turn into a bird to quickly scale
mountains or get the drop on enemies as
well as the appearance disguising power
of muspelheim all have their place
alongside traditional assassin's creed
abilities and tactics and they're
upgradeable if you find yourself relying
on one more than the others
these abilities weren't just picked
because they seemed cool either even
though they are with the team pulling
inspiration from ancient writings to
determine some of them power of the
raven for example came from a saga of
poetry that concluded with odin turning
into a bird in this case the bird was an
eagle so ubisoft sophia did not limit
itself to the literal text for its own
interpretation
choice is at the heart of dawn of
ragnarok's combat the same that can be
said for the rest of valhalla but the
difference is in the wild ways you can
turn the tide of battle via odin's
abilities i was most impressed by the
power of rebirth an ability that when
activated temporarily turns anyone odin
kills into an ally use it at an
opportune time such as when you're
facing an enormous number of enemies and
you can change the fight from being a
lost cause into an all-out slaughter in
your favor you do have to choose
carefully however as only a few of these
abilities can be equipped at a time
their use is also tied to a new resource
huger which you can get from enemies
certain objects in the environment and
shrines though the latter option
requires a sacrifice of health in order
to do so this give and take balancing of
these powers looks like it will be most
interesting in dawn of ragnarok's combat
arenas these gauntlets provide extra
combat challenges in exchange for ever
increasing rewards tied to their
difficulty rather than have you pick
normal or hard off a list you instead
get to have odin boast about an
accomplishment they made the more
bolsterous the harder the challenge will
be and extra modifiers can make things
even harder but if you're clever you can
actually make this work in your favor an
example shown during the demonstration
gave two extra layers of challenge in
addition to lowering odin's attack
damage with each subsequent blow it also
gave enemies higher damage however by
using the power of rebirth odin could
quickly dispatch a few enemies before
the damage reduction became an issue and
subsequently sent them after the
remaining enemies
that damage buff still applied to the
enemies now resurrected and fighting
their former brethren resulting in an
easier victory still you'll have to be
on your toes against even the smallest
group of baddies
these aren't mere humans armed with axes
and swords and spharthalheim but
powerful muscles
the creatures are capable of conjuring
fire spells and a flame keeper archetype
can also reignite fallen enemies and
send exploding furies to detonate around
odin
did my tail please you valkyrie have
more where that came from alongside the
mythical abilities odin also has an
entirely new weapon type in dawn of
ragnarok the atkid based on the viking's
own spear but resembling something out
of monster hunter it's a powerful
two-handed weapon with its own combo
system it's also capable of delivering
powerful blows into the ground as well
as swift attacks to take out several
enemies for those tired of axes that
valhalla featured so prominently it
looks to be a very different alternative
and one that's flashy enough to appeal
to character action game fans who can
imagine odin is dante or bayonetta
assassin's creed valhalla dawn of
ragnarok is shaping up to be the series
furthest leap into fantasy but as a
reflection of the beliefs of the norse
people during that time period it still
feels like a natural fit in the
assassin's creed universe despite
bearing little resemblance to the
adventures of ezio and altair it seems
to have a very good grasp on its own
identity and that's necessary in a game
you'll be playing for 35 hours
assassin's creed valhalla donna ragnarok
releases on ps4 ps5 xbox one xbox series
xms and pc on march 10.
oh
gentlemen
you